they also release this trailer you know
I get alerts on celebrities birthdays
it's Jon Bernthal birthday today so
happy happy Jon Bernthal hope you get to
spend it with your family that's alive
yeah that that dog that I think you have
I saw him on a talk show on sans dog
with what's going on reject nation Greg
outta here and John Humphrey over here
today we're gonna watch one egg and the
butter shirt one marvel show you're
still looking forward to yeah because
this was everything everyone wanted it
every so was the Inhumans let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
poor Shane some Metallica song
[Music]
[Music]
Oh CIA operation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sniper yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah Marvel you dicks budging that release
interval one damn release date of this
show they're gonna surprise this wrap it
into Netflix in a moment
oh man look really cool they look really
cool I know we've talked about this
Punisher that he did like solar reaction
on the first teaser I mind it looks like
what they said they're setting out to do
this extreme violent emotionally angry
rampage it's kind of like a John wick
meets what we'd expect from The Punisher
he was talking about making it
challenging and you're pushing the
audience to the edge and then bringing
him back each time and and it looks like
they could definitely do that if they
wanted yeah do you think they've changed
the origin a little bit with that whole
thing we're like his wife gets shot in
the face in their house
well I that look like a dream sequence
that registered like he's having a dream
that he's back with his wife and
everything is all good and then some guy
comes in Schuster the head yeah we all
had that dream usually it's me shooting
the one I'm dating usually it's you
shooting me yeah I get my girl back and
I just shoot I kind of wish the show was
lit and shot a little bit differently it
looks like it's lit in Shaa like all the
other Marvel Netflix shows yeah but
without really a distinct cinematography
appeal that's one thing that I feel like
is semi missing for me in this trailer
yeah I can see where you're coming from
every show has its own visual yeah
alloted I didn't get a distinct sense
for the visuals of this show yeah
because I feel like you know each one of
these guys in the defenders has a
specific color palette to whatever their
show is I feel like this is gonna be way
more of its own thing than it is wanting
to be like another defender show but you
know you got even got Karen page in the
trailer she's supposed to be in a lot of
the episodes you know the cop from
daredevil season 1 & 2 is back I forgot
that characters name we get like a hints
at the type of villain it is it seems
like the Punisher is gonna be having a
takedown something that's much more
legally challenging for to take down -
yeah are they taking most of this after
the events
yeah yeah yeah it's picking up right
after the events of daredevil the new
Punisher and I'm just gonna kill
everything I'm gonna kill specific it
seems like he's going after corruption
as well yeah more than just gangs he's
really going like he's like fighting
like SWAT members at one point in this
trailer yeah yeah but in terms of what I
want to see from the Punisher I feel
like it's really gonna deliver it's
gonna be as hard our violent show yeah
where there's the emotional rage while
he's fighting but I also having the rock
music go over it it's like that's kind
of what you'd want for the Punisher oh
yeah yeah punch is pretty heavy metal
and metallic is a good choice you get a
little bit of the emotional at the top
you know and then you get heavy yeah
yeah yeah that sound that sounds like
Frank Castle Steve Lightfoot did
Hannibal right so like I feel like that
you know showrunners for these things
tend to at least clue me in or give me
faith or give me doubts and I feel like
you know everybody loved Hannibal and
Hannibal was good at pushing the
boundaries and getting away with stuff
that you didn't think TV could get away
with and this is Netflix so like they're
less worse yeah Anna really heavily know
a lot about the Punisher after what
happens in season 2 of daredevil he's
not a big fan of working with other
people I doubt he's gonna assemble his
own team but it looks like there's a
couple of characters here like that guy
who's returning who's from the show
girls it seems like that's gonna be one
of his main people that he's gonna
partner up with Karen page I'm assuming
he's gonna get some help from her too
and they're gonna bring back way night
from Punisher war zone Oh that'd be cool
like arms supplier typically should get
John Travolta Baggins yeah definitely I
think we just kind of combined every
Punisher cameo and Dolph Lundgren it's
gonna well guys are you emotionally
satisfied with the trailer for The
Punisher on Netflix I'm gonna be
watching this show I am her as well it's
I've actually seen all the Netflix shows
I'm up to date yeah man every Netflix
show not even just now just the Mario
ranky - OH house of cards the British
version and the Netflix right subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell
dad is John Humphrey on Twitter and
and go check out our patreon become a
patron eject today and thank you to
everyone who's already over there on
patreon you guys have been amazingly
supportive and wonderful to interact
with